So what happens as we go down here, at least one vertex added and so on.
So what does this have to do with measuring the hardness of vertex cover?
Well, we'll get there in a minute.
What I would like you to think about now is the following:
Let's say we were looking at the decision variant of vertex cover
where as input we were given a graph and an integer K,
and our output was an answer to the question,
does the graph have a vertex cover of size at most K?
So now here comes my next question to you,
what is the maximum height of the search tree
if we are not using it to solve the optimization version of vertex cover
but the decision version of vertex cover?
Would that height be in half, would that height be K,
would that height be N, or something we can't say?
And please choose the best possible one here.